der neue corona grenzwert maximal 50
infektionen auf 100.000 einwohner
was folgt aus dieser zahl ein großer
schritt in hessen ab samstag sind dort
veranstaltungen mit bis zu 100
teilnehmern erlaubt und hilferufe der
kommunen wegen der pandemie brechen
steuereinnahmen weg es droht ein minus
von bis zu 60 milliarden euro
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend in allen die welt an diesem
donnerstag sieht so aus deutschland ist
auf dem schwierigen weg der einerseits
mehr freiheit im alltag bringen soll
andererseits nicht das aufs spiel setzen
darf was erreicht ist im kampf gegen
korona die bundesländer bauen auf ganz
unterschiedliche fahrpläne wir haben
gleich mehr dazu und es gibt über allem
einen mechanismus der einen rückfall
verhindern soll
diese art notbremse auf regionaler ebene
nimmt die einzelnen landkreise in die
pflicht sollte die zahl der
neuinfektionen in einem kreis einen
bestimmten wert überschreiten müssen die
behörden reagieren
derzeit ist das der fall nur in
thüringen im landkreis greiz melanie
haack und volker check berichten
schmucke häuschen und fachmärkte leids
und der gleichnamige landkreis im
thüringischen vogtland präsentieren sich
heute von ihrer postkarten seite
doch die idylle trügt greiz ist ein
brennpunkt 33 todesfälle durch corona
gab es bereits das entspricht einer
todesrate von rund 6,5 prozent
angeblicher auslöser vieler infektion
familienfeiern ende februar anfang märz
das landratsamt greiz muss die pandemie
managen viel verantwortung jetzt wartet
man auf beschlüsse der landesregierung
sehr positiv getestet es kommt in
quarantäne
wer nur kontaktperson ist und jetzt auch
mal negativ getestet ist ist in
praktisch sondern sagt dazu häusliche
isolation bund und länder haben gestern
einen notfallmechanismus verabredet wenn
in einem landkreis oder eine kreisfreie
stadt mehr als 50 nachgewiesene
neuinfektionen je 100.000 einwohner
innerhalb von sieben tagen auftreten
können regionale behörden wieder
beschränkungen aussprechen sind die
infektionsketten klar etwa in einem
pflegeheim können die einschränkungen
auf die einrichtung begrenzt werden
in greiz liegt die zahl der
neuinfektionen sogar bei 87,6 pro 100000
einwohner prinzipiell einverstanden mit
dieser notbremse ist auch das robert
koch institut
es wird künftig die gesundheitsämter mit
500 mitarbeitern aus den eigenen reihen
unterstützen
es ist ihre aufgabe fälle zu
identifizieren zu isolieren dann die
kontaktperson zu identifizieren und enge
kontakte
daneben unter quarantäne zu stellen
andere virologen glauben dass die ämter
die mehrarbeit nicht schaffen werden
da müssen sie jeden einzelnen fall
kontaktieren da müssen sie dessen
kontakten in den letzten fünf tagen nach
telefonieren also das ist in der
jetzigen situation einfach eine
überforderung der gesundheitsämter im
landkreis greiz rechnen die behörden mit
einem weiteren anstieg der infektionen
beim ersten massentest waren am
wochenende mehr als fünf prozent der
pflegekräfte und bewohner von
seniorenheimen positiv getestet worden
es gibt eine ganze reihe von daten und
zahlen die diese pandemie abbilden
hier kommen die aktuellen für
deutschland laut johns hopkins
universität und da ist der trend weiter
positiv er geht nach unten
durchschnittlich haben sich in den
vergangenen sieben tagen jeweils 950
menschen täglich neu angesteckt
insgesamt sind stand vor gut einer
halben stunde fast 100 69.000
infektionen durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten knapp 140000 betroffene als
genesen und 7322 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben
jedes bundesland geht in der pandemie
eigene wege aber für jede lockerung gilt
es muss ein hygiene konzept her und die
abstandsregeln gelten immer und überall
vor diesem hintergrund wagt hessen jetzt
einen schritt der so bundesweit einmalig
ist theater kinos und konzerthäuser
dürfen ab samstag wieder öffnen
veranstaltungen mit bis zu 100
teilnehmern sollen wieder möglich sein
im ausnahmefall dürfen behörden auch
noch mehr teilnehmer erlauben
peter wagner hat für uns diese
ankündigungen des hessischen
ministerpräsidenten verfolgt peter guten
abend was ist das für ein paket mit dem
hessen da loslegt
ja also es ist einfach so dass wie eben
kurz beschrieben veranstaltungen bis 100
personen dann möglich sind wenn alle
regeln eingehalten wenn das ist die
voraussetzung und außerdem dürfen
maximal zehn personen je 50 quadratmeter
zusammen seien denkbar wäre also dass
ein kino sei geöffnet wird dann aber nur
eine person pro reihe sitzen kann weil
man sonst nicht mehr aneinander vorbei
käme verantwortlich für sowas ist der
betreiber und es ist auch denkbar dass
veranstaltungen über 100 personen
vielleicht auch mit 500 vereinen
stattfinden können zum beispiel in einer
messehalle ein parteitag eine
hauptversammlung dazu braucht es dann
aber eine vorherige behördliche
genehmigung und da gilt wie überall es
müssen auch listen der anwesenden
personen geführt werden und verfügbar
sein
also eine ganze reihe von auflagen jetzt
hat hessens ministerpräsident bouffier
gesagt er wolle sich am wettbewerb der
bundesländer auf keinen fall beteiligen
hessen geht jetzt in einigen markanten
punkten aber doch vor allem auch im
bundesweiten vergleich was ist da der
hintergrund der leitgedanke so hat er
das eben und auch al-wazir sein
stellvertreter von den grünen eben
formuliert ist freiheit und
verantwortung wenn man schwenkt ja
unsere bürgerrechte stark ein und hat
das vorher auch stark getan und deswegen
so sagen die beiden politiker muss
sorgfältig abgewogen werden also in
zukunft deutlich mehr eigenverantwortung
der bürger der veranstalter der
gastwirte und weniger staatliches
eingreifen
aber all das gilt natürlich unter dem
vorbehalt dass die infektionszahlen
dadurch nicht wieder zu stark ansteigen
sonst wird auch zurückgefahren sagt
peter wagner in wiesbaden peter vielen
dank risiko gruppe das war immer schon
ein problematisches wort denn es geht um
unsere großeltern und unsere mütter und
väter gerade die von ihnen die besonders
hilfe brauchen sind aber in der krise
auch besonders betroffen nicht nur
gesundheitlich sie leiden darunter dass
sie seit wochen abgeschottet leben
müssen
jetzt wird auch in pflege- und
altersheimen das besuchsverbot gelockert
aufatmen aber auch bedenken wie bobby
cherry anzeigt seit heute sind in dieser
mainzer seniorenresidenz wieder besucher
erlaubt wie in ganz rheinland pfalz ein
besucher pro einwohner eine stunde am
tag eine entscheidung die zu früh kam
und die einrichtung unvorbereitet traf
so die heimleitung wir haben riesige
logistik werden 300 bewohner hier
ich kriege logistik gar nicht geschafft
jeden bewohner für jeden angehörigen
einmal täglich zu sehen das geht gar
nicht unter anderem müssen jetzt zwei
sogenannte plauder räume eingerichtet
werden ausreichend groß damit abstand
eingehalten werden kann und es braucht
desinfektionsmittel sowie
schutzausrüstung für bewohner und
besucher laut robert-koch-institut
stehen 37 prozent aller deutschen corona
infektionen im zusammenhang mit
krankenhäusern alten- und pflegeheimen
virologen warnen das besuchsverbot jetzt
aufzuheben berge risiken
am nachmittag besuchte die rheinland
pfälzische ministerpräsident in malu
dreyer selbst ein altenheim in mainz die
einrichtungen im land wieder zu öffnen
eine frage der abwägung wir wissen
einfach es gibt ganz viele sorgen bei
den älteren menschen weil sie sozial
isoliert sind weil sie zu wenig kontakt
mit den verwandten haben und deshalb
finde ich ist unsere maßnahme eine
moderate aber sehr richtige und hygiene
stand hat sind auch sehr sehr hoch und
ich denke wir gehen genau den richtigen
schritt an dieser stelle was die
abwägung betrifft für vorerst zwei
wochen ist das besuchsverbot aufgehoben
danach soll die korona lage in den alten
und pflegeheimen neu bewertet werden
der bundestag hat heute gesetze
beschlossen die eltern und studierende
in der korona krise entlasten sollen
wer jetzt als bafög empfänger in
systemrelevanten bereichen aus hilft zum
beispiel im krankenhaus job dessen lohn
wird nicht auf das bafög angerechnet die
hilfe wird also nicht gekürzt
auch beim elterngeld sollen mütter und
väter jetzt keine einbußen haben
wenn jemand wegen der pandemie aktuell
weniger verdient soll das nicht in die
berechnung des elterngeldes einfluss
deutschland hat eine neue
wehrbeauftragte eva högl von der spd
heute hat sie der bundestag gewählt
damit ist eine personalie entschieden
die für die spd fraktion zur
zerreißprobe wurde weil da noch zwei
weitere interne kandidaten waren die
sich am ende unfair behandelt fühlten
britta spiekermann berichtet bislang hat
rolf mützenich seine spd fraktion ruhig
durch schwere gewässer gesteuert
doch zuletzt sorgte die frau hinter ihm
die personalie eva högl für turbulenzen
die bundeswehr sei für sie politisches
neuland hügel sei ungeeignet
wehrbeauftragte zu werden hörte man
vielstimmig aus der opposition
fraktionschef mützenich verteidigt die
nominierung auch gegen innerparteiliche
kritik ich habe mich dann am ende für
eva högl entschieden eine exzellente
juristinnen die sich in den vergangenen
jahren sehr stark mit dem beamten aber
auch soldaten recht befasst hat seine
entscheidung für hügel ist auch eine
entscheidung gegen den spd-mann johannes
chaos der hatte bereits dienstag alle
ämter hingeschmissen chaos oberst der
reserve wollte eigentlich
wehrbeauftragter werden
chancenlos auch der frühere amtsinhaber
hans peter bartels in den vergangenen
jahren hat er sich einen guten ruf
erworben
doch der spd-fraktionschef entschied
sich gegen mütze nicht bekennender
pazifist will offenbar ein anderer eine
neue verteidigungspolitische ausrichtung
wahlgang mit abstand im bundestag es
dauert stunden bis klar ist hügel ist
gewählt
ich freue mich sehr und nehme die wahl
an vielen dank die opposition kann
dieser mal nichts abgewinnen
wir werden natürlich jetzt genau schauen
ob vögel wirklich für die soldatinnen
soldaten da ist oder der verlängerte arm
von der mütze nicht von dem wir wissen
dass er die bundeswehr ablehnt und hügel
muss jetzt und das vertrauen das kaputt
gegangen ist natürlich bei den
soldatinnen und soldaten werben
sie muss überzeugen dass sie ein
interesse am thema hat dass er bereit
ist sich ein zug nähert sich
einzuarbeiten auch in die fach thematik
die erfahrene innenexpertin muss jetzt
beweisen dass sie auch gute truppe kann
es ist das vorläufige ende eines macht
und posten spiels in der spd auf den
innenminister des saarlands klaus
bouillon ist möglicherweise ein anschlag
versucht worden
unbekannte sollen den dienstwagen des
innenministers in st wendel manipuliert
haben ein warnsystem des autos habe den
72 jährigen cdu politiker der selbst
fuhr jedoch informiert die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft saarbrücken
ermittelt jetzt wegen des verdachts des
versuchten mordes und susanne freitag
beobachtet das ganze für uns in
saarbrücken susanne was wissen denn die
ermittler bisher also was inzwischen
wirklich bestätigt wurde ist dass die
räder des wagens von klaus bouillon
manipuliert wurden es soll sich dabei um
einen oder mehrere täter handeln das ist
noch nicht bekannt geworden
der wagen stand vor dem privathaus des
ministers er war mehrere tage dort und
regelmäßig fahren dort polizeistreifen
vorbei man weiß nicht genau wann diese
manipulationen stattgefunden hat der
minister hat es gemerkt weil er sein
auto selbst gefahren hat es ging ein
warnsignal los er ist daraufhin in eine
werkstatt gefahren und dort wurde
festgestellt der wagen ist manipuliert
worden
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
jetzt sie ermittelt in alle richtungen
man kann derzeit auch nicht ausschließen
heißt es da dass es sich um einen
staatsfeindlichen beziehungsweise einen
terroristischen hintergrund handelt die
polizei hat einen zeugenaufruf an die an
die bevölkerung gerichtet
mehr weiß man zur stunde nicht und mehr
wird man heute auch nicht erfahren in
die staatsanwaltschaft hat gesagt dass
sie heute dazu keine weiteren auskünfte
geben wird susanne freitag zdf
saarbrücken herzlichen dank dafür
unser nächstes thema weniger einnahmen
zusätzliche ausgaben mit den
finanziellen folgen der korona krise
haben auch deutschlands kommunen zu
kämpfen
es geht um ein riesiges loch in ihren
kassen bis zu 60 milliarden euro könnten
in diesem jahr fehlen schätzt der
deutsche städte und gemeindebund
denn während ausgaben zum beispiel bei
den gesundheitsämtern steigen brechen
einnahmen wie die gewerbesteuer
dramatisch ein
auf die sind die kommunen aber
angewiesen zeigt david sauer kommunen
haben ein grundgesetzlich verbrieftes
recht auf selbstverwaltung und
finanzhoheit demnach sind die länder
verpflichtet kommunen so auszustatten
dass sie alle angelegenheiten der
örtlichen gemeinschaft selbstständig
erfüllen können das geld dafür kommt im
wesentlichen aus gebühren und beiträgen
zum beispiel für die müllabfuhr sowie
vor allem aus zuweisungen und steuern
das steueraufkommen der kommunen setzt
sich zusammen aus der besonders
konjunkturabhängigen gewerbesteuer
anteilen an der einkommen- und
umsatzsteuer sowie der grundsteuer
zuweisungen erhalten kommunen vor allem
von den ländern wenige vom bund damit
finanzieren sie überwiegend allgemeine
ausgaben es gibt einen finanzausgleich
zwischen starken und schwachen kommunen
und einen teil der zuweisungen ist
zweckgebunden für bestimmte
investitionen die aktuelle krise trifft
die kommunen doppelt die steuereinnahmen
brechen ein und die ausgaben für
sozialleistungen steigen so und was
bedeutet das alles konkret für die
bürger worauf müssen sie sich einrichten
die antwort in kürze vieles könnte
teurer werden kita-gebühren
eintrittsgelder zum beispiel oder
leistungen der gemeinden werden gekürzt
schlimmstenfalls ganz gestrichen
isabel de la vega hat das in gelnhausen
in hessen und engagiert das idyllische
23.000 einwohner städtchen gelnhausen
hängt finanziell von seinen unternehmen
ab automobil und bauzulieferer
große handwerksbetriebe mit corona sind
hier die gewinne eingebrochen und damit
auch die einnahmen der stadt der
bürgermeister macht sich sorgen die
situation momentan ist sehr gravierend
durch den einbruch der gewerbesteuer
dass bis zu 30 40 prozent ausmachen kann
hat die stadt ein enormes finanzprobleme
und das wird dazu führen dass wir hier
in der stadt entscheidende maßnahmen
treffen müssen die letztendlich die
gesamte bevölkerung mit tragen muss
gelnhausen wächst und das wird
investiert zb in eine neue große kita
nach dem einbruch der steuereinnahmen um
geschätzte fünf bis sechs millionen wird
jetzt über eine erhöhung der
kita-gebühren nachgedacht und über
höhere eintrittspreise fürs freibad oder
für kulturelle veranstaltungen corona
wird sich dramatisch auf die einnahmen
der städte und kommunen in ganz
deutschland aus in der finanzkrise hat
mir einen rückgang der gewerbesteuer um
20 prozent was auch schon vieles jetzt
gehen wir von deutlich höheren zahlen
aus
30-40 möglicherweise 50% wir haben
steigende sozialkosten bei menschen in
die arbeitslosigkeit geraten
also wir brauchen ganz klar die hilfe
von bund und ländern das land hessen ist
beim thema finanzspritze zurückhaltend
wir haben ein gemeinsames problem wunsch
länder und kommunen das müssen wir lösen
aber zurzeit ist es noch zu früh dort
sehr konkret zu werden
lange kann bürgermeister glöckner nicht
warten im herbst muss er die ersten
sparmassnahmen angehen wenn keine hilfe
von bund und ländern kommt zwei tage
lang herrschte ziemliche funkstille im
turm der europäischen zentralbank nach
dem urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
das hat er das billionenschwere
anleihekaufprogramm der bank zum teil
für verfassungswidrig erklärt jetzt hat
sich deren präsidentin christine lagarde
geäußert sehr eindeutig die ezb werde
unbeirrt weiterhin tun was nötig sei
sagte sie der nachrichtenagentur
bloomberg die bank sei unabhängig und
müsse nur dem europäischen parlament
gegenüber rechenschaft ablegen und jetzt
ins ausland in polen sollte am sonntag
ein neuer präsident gewählt werden
eigentlich jetzt wird die abstimmung
wegen corona auf einen späteren noch
nicht bekannten zeitpunkt verschoben
darauf hat sich das regierungsbündnis
unter führung der nationalkonservativen
pis partei geeinigt die geplante wahl
war umstritten
die opposition hatte kritisiert wegen
der pandemie sei kein wahlkampf möglich
und deswegen sei der von der pis
unterstützte amtsinhaber andré du da im
vorteil
unsere korrespondenten in warschau ist
natalie steger natalie guten namen was
hat denn jetzt den ausschlag gegeben
diese wahl zu verschieben
also da ist sicherlich auch einfach der
faktor zeit eine große rolle gespielt
die pis will die wahlen als komplette
briefwahl abhalten ein novum in polen
und das hätte allein organisatorisch
natürlich nicht geklappt bis sonntag
wies parteichef kaczynski muss man sagen
hatte sich und seine partei in die
klemme manövriert er hatte bis zuletzt
auf biegen und brechen auf geht's dem
kommenden sonntag bestanden weil sein
kandidat amtsinhaber duda in allen
umfragen führt klar die opposition lief
sturm aber auch der kleine
koalitionspartner in der regierung
muckte auf die wollten die wahlen
nämlich gleich mal um zwei jahre
verschieben also ein kompromiss musste
her die regierung hat sich geeinigt die
wahlen werden verschoben
gleichzeitig plant peilt man einen
frühstmöglichen zeitpunkt an
schon in diesem sommer vielen dank
natalie und jetzt nach israel
dort hat das parlament die weichen
gestellt für die neue einheitsregierung
von ministerpräsident benjamin netanyahu
und ex armeechef benny gantz die knesset
erlaubte per gesetz das das amt des
ministerpräsidenten
zwischen ganz und netanyahu rotieren
darf nächste woche soll die koalition
vereidigt werden
gestern hatte das oberste gericht
erlaubt dass netanyahu eine neue
regierung bilden kann
obwohl gegen ihn eine anklage wegen
korruption vorliegt wieder gibt es
schlechte nachrichten vom
us-arbeitsmarkt 3,2 millionen menschen
haben in der vergangenen woche
arbeitslosenhilfe beantragt damit haben
mehr als 33 millionen menschen in den
usa seit beginn der korona krise ihren
job verloren
die arbeitslosenquote liegt nach
inoffiziellen angaben bei 16 prozent
im märz waren es noch gut 4 prozent
einsames training im kraftraum statt
kicken im stadion das war wochenlang die
realität der bundesliga-profis corona
pause jetzt geht es wieder los erster
spieltag ist der 16
ein corona experiment mit regelmäßigen
tests und vielen fragen was wenn sich
ein spieler trotzdem an steckt muss dann
das ganze team in quarantäne fabia
meseberg hat mehr am samstag in einer
woche geht es mit dem spieltag weiter
der auf grund der korona krise mitte
märz als erstes ausfallen musste
höhepunkt das revierderby dortmund gegen
schalke diesmal vor leeren rängen
eine woche vor dem ersten spiel werden
sich alle mannschaften den hygiene
konzept der dfl folgend eine woche lang
isolieren
ich finde wir haben hier eine
verantwortung nicht nur den den den
schein zu wahren sondern halt auch
dieses konzept umzusetzen weil wir
wollen natürlich auch keine gesundheit
gefährden wir wollen gesunde spieler
haben und wir wollen ein vorbild sein
bei einer infizierung nur den
betroffenen in quarantäne zu schicken
könnte eine schwäche des concept sein
ansonsten aber genießt es vor allem im
ausland schon jetzt hohes ansehen denn
international stehen die großen ligen in
allen sportarten still
das interesse an diesem konzept ist
riesig groß ich weiß nicht ob man das
konzept eins zu eins in anderen ländern
so umsetzen kann aber wie es gerade
sagte wir werden das wissen daraus auch
die art und weise was wie man damit
umgeht auch ehrlich gesagt was wir alles
falsch machen natürlich werden die dinge
auch falsch machen das gehört zum leben
dazu
aber all das werden wir
selbstverständlich teilen auch die
premier league in england würde gerne
weiterspielen ein konkretes konzept gibt
es noch nicht deshalb wird auch hier die
bundesliga ganz genau beobachtet wenn
deutschland das kann warum wir nicht aus
das ist ganz klar ein vorbild für den
englischen fußball
aber nur wenn das hygiene konzept der
dfl von einem beteiligten bedingungslos
umgesetzt wird
und jetzt es ist zeit danke zu sagen hat
sich der geheimnisvolle
street-art-künstler banksy gedacht und
tut das so wie er es am besten kann
mit einem bild und einer botschaft wer
braucht schon batman und spiderman wenn
da eine echte heldin ist bis zum herbst
bleibt das gemälde bei den mitarbeitern
und patienten der uniklinik southhampton
im süden von england
dann wird es versteigert und natürlich
ganz heldenhaft für einen guten zweck
das wetter bleibt sonnig und es wird
noch wärmer alle details gleich von
gunther tiersch kurz vor 10 ist der
kollege claus kleber hier mit dem
heute-journal jetzt gleich an pieper mit
einem zdf spezial corona krise warnt
lockert europa wir sagen danke für ihr
großes interesse gern bis morgen aber
erst in allen einen angenehmen
donnerstagabend tschüss
[Musik]
und da bliebe zuschauer morgen ist der
himmel nicht mehr so tief wie heute
heute hatten den strahlenden
sonnenschein auch an den küsten und in
norddeutschland wurde ist am nachmittag
sonnig jetzt tauchen im westen diese
hohen schleierwolken auf die heute nacht
über deutschland hinwegziehen richtig
kalt wird es eigentlich nur im norden da
kann es durchaus mal bodenfrost geben
morgen haben wir auch immer wieder
wolkenfelder durchziehen aber der sonne
charakter bleibt und vor allen dingen an
den küsten strahlenden sonnenschein bei
diesem kräftigen westwind so am späten
nachmittag frühen abend kam es dann
allerdings im schwarzwald auf der
schwäbischen alb vielleicht mal
regenschauer geben
die temperaturen steigen an den küsten
auch 16 17 grad aber warm wird es im
landesinneren 20 bis 26 grad am
oberrhein und in den nächsten tagen
haben den wetterwechsel mit schauern und
gewittern am wochenende vor allem am
sonntag und am montag dann könnte es
tatsächlich in den mittelgebirgen auch
mal schneien
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut